Я виїхав через погрози. Це рішення ми ухвалили за один вечір.
Мене могли посадити на кілька років.
Я допомагав сестрі з агітацією за Тихановську.
У мене тут написано, що досить нас катувати.
Білорусь - це вільна країна!
Нас не катують - нас убивають!
У мене зневіра та тотальна депресія! Я просто не можу знаходитися в цій державі!
Цей режим був спочатку таким собі фарсом, який мав би закінчитися
уже через 5 років, але ніяк не закінчується.
Протести у Мінську не вщухають уже тиждень.
Акції солідарності з білорусами відбуваються і в Києві.
Для багатьох білорусів Україна стає другою домівкою.
Приїжджають хто на навчання, хто на роботу,
а хто тікає від політичних переслідувань.
18-ти-річний  Ілля Бондаренко підтримував Світлану Тихановську,
поширював її передвиборчу агітацію.
Якщо протестувальникам у Білорусі не вдасться домогтися відставки Лукашенка,
то повернутися додому він скоріш за все не зможе.
Ілля мріє стати перекладачем, але в лукашенківській Білорусі,
де все іноземне автоматично означає "вороже", його майбутня спеціальність не затребувана.
У нас людей усе ще навчають, як в СРСР.
Мовляв, решта країн - це погано. Україна - погано, Росія - погано, ЄС - погано.
Все погано - тільки в нас добре, бо в нас стабільність.
Так нас вчать у школі і по телебаченню.
Аліна Заміровська має освіту перекладачки з французької та англійської.
Виїхала з Білорусі кілька років тому насамперед з економічних причин.
Каже, що з її дипломом могла знайти роботу лише за межами своєї країни.
Білорусь на чолі з Лукашенком вона порівнює з СРСР 70-тих років
і вважає таку атмосферу отруйною для себе і своїх дітей.
Можуть погрожувати, що поставлять на облік "соціально-небезпечного становища".
Можуть дітей забрати. Можуть, якщо ви щось не те зробили,
що не подобається державі, якось так до вас підкопатися.
Жінка уважно стежить за подіями в Білорусі.
Зізнається, що на виборах не підтримувала жодного кандидата.
Усі опозиційні кандидати, на її думку, не мали достатнього досвіду
та потенціалу для демократичних перетворень у країні.
Аліна виступає за призначення нових виборів у Білорусі,
в яких змогли б взяти участь заарештовані опозиціонери,
і тримає кулаки за своїх співвітчизників,
які домагаються цього на мирних протестах.
Мені здається, що Лукашенко просто не зможе залишитися,
якщо народ буде продовжувати вперто виходити на вулиці,
якщо будуть дійсно серйозні спроби зупинити економічне життя країни.
Йому просто доведеться з цим рахуватися.
Але цим може скористатися Росія, і ми можемо втратити свою незалежність.
Російська загроза цілком реальна, вважає студент політології
Київського національного університету Євген Тимошевич.
Адже, на його думку, російські війська можуть
через відкриті кордони зайти в Білорусь без жодного спротиву.
Тема моєї дипломної роботи була
"Виборча система України та Білорусі. Порівняльний аналіз".
Виникла запекла дискусія з комісією. Ми перейшли на відверті крики.
Тому що один з членів комісії стверджував, що анексія Криму не є анексією,
а є, мовляв, законним актом, який здійснила Росія.
Євген шкодує, що не може наразі долучитися до протестувальників.
Як майбутній політолог він вважає, що білоруси нині мають унікальний шанс
стати на шлях сучасної і демократичної держави.
Треба дати поштовх реформам, перейти від ручного керування,
коли президент керує тренуванням хокейної команди,
коли президент одноосібно керує економікою,
коли президент одноосібнокерує посівною, доїнням корів.
Має бути якесь делегування повноважень!
Влада не може бути зосереджена в одних руках!
25-річний радіофізик Стась Красулін залишив країну,
бо не бачив для себе жодних перспектив у лукашенківській Білорусі.
Стало зрозуміло, що мені не дадуть завершити моє навчання
і, можливо, спробують примусово забрати на службу в армію,
яку нині Лукашенко і його нелегітимний уряд
використовують проти власного народу.
Стась дуже цінує переваги, які дає йому життя в Україні -
навіть елементарна можливість вільно висловлювати свої думки.
Але сподівається, що до таких драматичних подій,
як у Києві під час Євромайдану, в Мінську не дійде.
Різниця в тому, що в Білорусі люди по суті своїй не войовничі.
Протест все одно мирний.
Люди намагаються - якби по-звірячому не діяла б влада -
вони продовжують діяти законними методами.
Я намагаюся бути обережно оптимістичним.
Таке було вже не раз.
І нині не зрозуміло, як на це відреагує влада, яка не готова на діалог.
Білоруси, які з тих чи інших причин нині живуть в Україні,
дуже переймаються за долю своїх рідних та близьких на батьківщині.
Але готові повернутися лише в Білорусь без Лукашенка.